[Music]
hi my name is Carmen Christopher and I'm
running for mayor because I want to get
this town in shape I think if you have a
body you should have a hard body
[Music]
[Applause]
definitely helped out my dues so that's
half mine hi I'm Garrett - CIN and I'm
running for mayor because this town
needs to get its paper straight
I've been balling since I was a young
and it started as a hobby Oh what's up
bitch my name is John Randall how about
my aunt's boyfriend's call me J ball
pizza ass and why am i running for town
mayor let's just say I grew up with 33
brothers and sisters and my dad's a
milkman yeah maybe
he's dead nice the only thing that sucks
about being buff is you just can't fit
into stuff I can't fit under this dang
mouch given an ass hip in this thing I
can't even spit down the dang sidewalk
but I can smash your freaking car
he's got my vote one thing's for sure
I'm most definitely not running for
mayor to impress my girlfriend Jessica
what I bring to the table is simple I'm
rich I'm strong and I'm nasty as hell I
can get anything I want
take it how about you let me get that
ice cream cone no mister
it's it sucks your personal
like that again i'ma make one phone call
your head off alright he's got
my vote
an Asian also I wouldn't be caught dead
running for mayor to impress my
girlfriend Jessica no way
[Music]
onomatopoeia malapropism xylophone just
some of the words that I know where the
I go school let's just say it's called
rock and roll middles did I mention that
my dad owns a Ruby Thursday he's got my
boat looking I'm not running for mayor
just to impress my girlfriend Jessica
girlfriend sounds weird to say hey nice
oh now hey babe here's your dream stone
cold
[Music]
the results are in mayor de bibbidi beef
o wins in an uncontested landslide
although there were three other
applicants their paperwork was rejected
due to being sticky and folded these are
the applicants walking right behind me
now as I talked to you at home
and I'm still on camera and still
talking I hope you're enjoying watching
this newscast as much as I am giving it
which is to say about normal amount
[Music]
[Applause]
sad man's Creek lore has it years ago in
1969 three sad men drowned here some say
every year they return at the stroke of
midnight to haunt these four oh hell
yeah I'm game
[Music]
we're satisfied to the core
we got a whole lot and so I'm okay with
me I'm okay with you we're just a couple
of days
[Music]